Hello everybody, welcome back to Doom 65.
Oh, hello.
Oh, howdy.
Howdy-duty.
Hello.
Oh, I don't want it to go into the demo mode.
Start up.
It's been like looping for so long.
Wait, you know, if I just press star, okay, there we go.
I think now it will be fine.
Dropping this to say, howdy.
Howdy.
It's my birthday!
Oh.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Dokoyon.
Happy birthday!
Oh my goodness.
We're like barely into the stream.
I already got a birthday.
Thanks!
Uma Musume Global release!
Wait, oh that's not what you said.
That's what Viralit said.
Oh, thanks for manifesting.
Yeah, Numa Musume.
Yeah!
Guys, I'm manifesting everything, basically.
Manifested.
manifested Metal Gear manifested Umamushime the world is
listening to me
is archive supposed to be on I guess it's fine but I don't
want people being delayed so I turn it off you come to the
stream you come for the very exact moment that's happening
thanks for letting me know I didn't realize Can You Manifest
MGS Master Collection 2 Soon Things?
Did you see that there was like, they were like, Oh, games
coming soon to PS5?
And one of them was Metal Gear Solid 4.
And I was like, I don't know if I believe that.
Well, I'll believe it when I see it.
You know?
Can You Manifest Me Million Dollars?
I was watching a clip the other day of Nero Sama playing...
who wants to be a millionaire that made me want to play who
wants to be a millionaire but but I kind of want to play it
with somebody but it's also one of those types of games that
you can only play it you shouldn't play with other people
you know what I mean
anyway we're back to Doom 64 the only thing they fear is you
meant as they should I have another meeting tonight you guys
I have three meetings today holy cow well two of them were
about two of them the two this morning were for conventions
so but they've already been about announced conventions but
then I have another one tonight and so i was like oh my
goodness busy busy day so i gotta get through this game i
gotta i gotta i gotta i gotta get through it manifesting
minto goon like uh like dragoon minto goon hoping to see you
at vtuber expo yeah yippee
So we must mint and tear.
Theo Kras!
Thanks for the 10 gifted, thank you!
Excited for virtual vacations!
Wait, can I show you guys something real quick?
I moved some stuff around.
You're only gonna see my head here, okay.
Um, wait, hold on.
Uh, there we go.
You're gonna, look.
I have an ad corner now.
Look at my ad corner.
I have an ad I was like I think I should maybe do that
because I have things to advertise now you're not there it
is virtual vacation things to advertise kind of skip ads
stop at vlog not work I take back your birthday wish so um
yeah these are events and things I'm going to and doing and
the podcast episode 13 went up today
yeah um so uh yeah other conventions and and the such is the
birthday with wish also sponsored look you guys now that I'm
indie if I get sponsored I get all the money so you know
what I've been being a little busy bee oh a busy little bee
no I want to be a little busy be where it means I'm a little
busy but I'm also a buddy good luck coffee don't get stuck
at the same level that made me give up oh so I realize why
the game has been oh hold on let's load it I realize why the
game has been easier and it's because I believe um I'm on
normal mode but with less monsters but you know what it's
fine Because, um, I'm having fun, so whatever.
You, you keep the money.
Oh, Oscar.
Someone tell me there's a problem with my AI.
What's wrong?
My childhood.
I know.
Oh, Oscar.
You keep the money.
You just promo clip boomer for a 10% discount on your
birthday, Sasha.
Oh my god, scatfully!
Thank you for the hot goes over.
This is a sponsored super chat.
I am the sponsor, that is all.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Is that guy dead?
Let me know how the audio is, by the way, too.
I have to remember how to play.
Um, okay, hold on.
So...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Eight.
Oh, three.
You killed him five seconds before a save.
Wow, we... I have a question.
Does Doom 64 I know with, like, regular, with Doom 1 and 2,
the bit rate would be, like, insanely bad while playing.
Is that the same with Doom 64, or is it not so bad?
How do I stop running?
I guess I don't need to know how to stop running.
I just need to...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Are they coming this way?
Oh, they're coming this way.
They're coming this way.
They're coming this way!
Yeah, take that, bozo.
How's the audio?
Just let me know.
I can make it better or worse.
Audio's okay, it's not too loud.
Thank you.
I hear more.
Someone's still throwing stuff at me.
How do I get up there?
Oh.
Hello?
Let me in, please.
Rapunzel, Rapunzel.
Let's down your long hair.
How do I get...
Oh, there was a...
The stairs over here wasn't there.
Blender Blast, thank you for a whole month.
Thank you.
Oh, there's also over here.
Wait, hold on.
Let's see if we can take down.
What the...
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Ah!
It's a spider demon!
Maybe this thing would be good.
Oh, shoot.
Take out one thing, at least.
Take out.
Take it out.
Oh, they're
fighting.
Oh, shoot.
I got hit.
They're infighting.
The girls are fighting.
Who's going to win?
Uh-oh.
I think they'll win.
Oh.
I took them out.
Ow!
Oh, my God.
What the?
How the hell?
That's so unfair!
Don't hurt me from here!
How?
Oh, let's open up.
Overkill.
It's fine.
That was insanity.
I'm just taking all the bullets.
Ooh, I'm hearing.
Okay, let's go upstairs.
Minton tear!
I had to un-make him.
Oh!
That's- Dogs may be able to look up, but Doom Mint can't.
How do I get to this thing?
Um, how do I interact with stuff, actually, now I think
about it?
Was it E?
E to interact?
Yes.
Where are you?
Someone.
Okay, I was just gonna...
Oh, wait.
Is there a thing?
Oh, no, I can't group that.
Grab that.
You gotta believe.
I'm just gonna ignore those guys.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is a Cocoa Deep.
Ow, gosh.
I hate the lost souls, you sons of bitches.
Uh, what's five?
Nope, that's not what I meant to do.
But you know what?
It works.
I'm at four!
There we go.
Raylan, thank you for the 50 gift attack!
Thank you so much.
Anybody in here?
Some uglies over here.
Nice gifts.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Really do appreciate it.
Oh, this guy.
Just wanted to share that my family and I celebrated our
cat's birthday today.
Oh, happy birthday to your cat.
Can I get this guy?
He doesn't know I'm here, idiot.
Idiot.
hearing so many people i'm scared of that room
it's a monster oh oh my god again wait oh they're all stuck
in here you activated my trap card
happy birthday to the cat
But anyways, how are you guys doing?
Sorry.
Oh, good.
For some reason, I keep thinking they're gonna be able to
hit me, but I know they're not.
I love old game limitations!
I'm sick!
I'm sick of you!
I'm just kidding.
I hope you feel better.
Sorry, you're sick.
Sick in the head.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm sorry, you're sick.
Sorry you're not feeling well.
This sucks.
Oh, there's a lot of guys in there.
Wait a second.
Let's get a...
Anybody left?
Nobody left.
Oh!
I
get him?
No, I don't even get him.
Oh my god, he's scared!
me it really spooked me ah sorry it's always these guys
these guys will actually be the death of me i think these
little losers
oh blueberry blueberry blueberry ah
here they oh here they go
Rip it down!
Am I even hitting anybody?
I can't even tell just die!
So many tomatoes.
A spicy meatball!
These guys are more meatball-y than before.
I can't get them from here very easily.
Let's get them from down here.
There we go.
That'll teach them.
Blueberry.
Hey, but we lost no health, even though we got the
blueberry.
Very good.
So that's going to go up into there.
Sorry, I'm just trying to get my bearings.
Oh, this is water.
No one else.
Only a barbecue.
Those are some angry meatballs.
Yeah, these guys are pretty meatball-like, when...
Oh, ouch.
I'm trying to grab their shotguns.
I'm too fast.
Too furious.
Spray and pray.
Yeah!
That is the basis of all combat.
I hate you guys!
But there is definitely some guys I haven't gotten yet.
If I don't want to leave yet.
Wait, also, how do I leave?
Wait.
Hmm.
Huh.
Curious.
Oh.
But there's some guys I haven't gotten yet.
No secret.
See?
You can hear him.
Where are they?
Oh no, this is where I just came from.
Hello.
Where are you at?
One store?
Peter, thanks for the super chat.
Really appreciate it.
Oh yeah, like it through here.
Check your map.
Wait, how do I zoom out again?
I'm gonna give one little run around and if I can't find
these losers.
I'm out of here.
Wait, what is this?
The golden cube.
Draco's thanks for the 10 gifted.
Also, this right right here?
There's so much here!
Hmm.
And that back- wait.
I think I can get to that, right?
Hold on.
Wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I got a super
shotgun.
Oh, I already had that.
But, how do I...
See, I think I need to, like, walk along this, right?
How do I get...
Oh.
Oh, oops.
Okay, hold on.
I have really...
secret found.
I have really short legs.
Okay, hold on.
Get up here.
Or really bad balance is what I meant to say.
Oh no!
I think I give up.
I don't need a backpack.
What am I?
What am I a baby?
Go up.
Lift up?
No?
Never mind.
What about over?
Oh!
There's just some random running around.
What are you guys doing?
They're running around like they own the place.
Yeah.
They're like, we're the pinkies.
We're the pinkies.
Oh, here too.
Okay.
There's another one.
Another little.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, nice.
Where are the pinkies?
What is this?
I guess I think it's a rocket launcher.
And then this opens up here.
Ah, ha, ha.
Okay, I think we actually got it now.
Let us leave.
Rocket launcher.
Okay.
Have fun ripping and tearing.
Thank you.
Well, I thought I got some secrets, but you know, whatever,
I guess.
What's this thing?
Oh!
No secrets here.
Why can't I grab it, though?
What?
What's that?
What's the point?
Oh my god, oh my god, I just realized everything that's
here!
Change!
Save?
Oh, thank you.
I shall save, yes.
Oh.
Oh!
I got the chain gun!
Sorry,
sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, everybody.
I lost my whole blueberry in one room.
Red key.
I'm so sorry.
We're fine.
I would have bought gamer subs if not.
Oh, I wouldn't have bought gamer subs if not for your boomer
code.
Ah, thank you for using it.
Appreciate it.
Maybe one day I can get a cup or a flavor.
Ooh.
That was very cool.
Let's load the game.
I'm not starting this level.
Okay.
Okay, we know that that box in the middle is evil.
Evil, evil.
I don't even know why.
It does that.
It's so evil.
I saw a guy over there.
Oh, the you can see them.
See, he's kind of behind the pillar.
Okay, I'm just going to go in with the chain gun, though.
Shout out to that save reminder.
I know, I know, for real.
Whoever told me to save, you're the best.
Oucha!
Oh.
Look at that.
Look at that difference.
The difference in everything.
But this, like, blew up, right?
When I got it.
I don't know why.
I'm just gonna leave it up there for now.
Okay.
Next room is also dangerous.
This couldn't be the level that people were talking about.
That's so scary, right?
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Ah!
I hear
them.
I hear them.
Yeah, take that.
Take that.
Oh, I think he's dead.
Quiet.
Sneaky!
Sneaky skull!
Oh, oh!
Even sneakier skull!
What the heck?
You fight demons good.
Thanks, and the wrath allows.
Thank you.
Oh, I thought this was like a berry.
I can't even see in there.
I'm gonna go back to the chain gun.
Oh!
Blueberry!
Blueberry.
How do I get this guy?
Ah!
Wait.
Oh!
Did I miss it?
Did I miss my shot?
Oh.
Short king.
The guy doesn't know how to use his arms.
I don't think he's ever used the ones in his life.
Actually, actually, I'm kind of confused.
How do I get out of here?
Now that I think about it.
I thought this was an exit, but it's not.
Oh, sorry.
Did you guys see the mata?
I'm not a fan.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry, I didn't realize you guys.
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
I understand what that was now.
my luck is kind of bad yeah
oh actually we need more armor I guess this is oh oh wait
can I get out of here oh here we go oh Restart?
Oh, shoot.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
In the meantime, they were able to reload.
Are you just watching it lower?
It was so...
Okay, this thing explodes, doesn't it?
Oh.
Yippee!
Oh, oh my goodness.
Oh my goodness.
I think I'm...
Ah!
Shoot!
Shoot and kill!
Kill!
Rip and tear!
Rip and tear while I'm alive.
Oh my god.
I'm out of ammo!
This isn't so great.
I
need to get this guy over here.
Dude.
Okay.
Now I feel a little bit more safe.
Well, safe is, you know.
Okay, we got him.
Oh, we got him.
Okay.
Can I touch this?
Can't tell if it's lava or like.
Where does it go?
I'm so curious.
Try it.
I think I can lick it.
Riyakari, thanks for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Good, we got more bullets.
Oh, that's health.
Sorry, I'm just looking.
Do you think I can lick it or...
It turns my gun red.
Ooh.
Feels kind of nice.
Actually, like when I get really close,
I feel like I'm moving.
I feel like I'm actually going up.
Oh, okay.
Now demonic.
Was there a switch over here or something?
Where's there?
Oh, here.
Oh!
Um, you guys are terrible.
Why are you in jail?
Give you the after-credit scroll syndrome.
I know.
Yeah,
you can see the buttholes like really clearly right now.
Like just gaping, gaping, gaping buttholes on all of these
guys.
Oh, sorry.
My head's blocking the butthole.
Oh, ViviCorps thinks you're the gifted.
So let's welcome the membership.
Indecent exposure.
What if they're like the Romeo and Juliet of demons, you
know?
Let's go to the other side.
You?
Okay.
Wait, there's more?
Oh, I thought I killed you.
There we go.
Get his butt.
Why are all these guys in jail?
And...
Not you.
You.
Wait, that's a big guy.
Hold on.
Ah!
I got stuck on something.
Yeah!
Did I just see?
Did I just see one of those little skulls?
I think so.
Or I saw something, right?
Oh!
Yes, I did!
Oh, my God.
You son of a gun.
I think there's one in there, too.
Yeah.
Okay.
him oh there's more can i stop missing for two seconds thank
you i'm trying to strafe but i guess i don't need to because
he's slow slow as molasses demon oh my god leave me alone
i'm trying to kill another demon what are you so obsessed
with dying uh oh
skull ain't slow.
Look, they were idols on the stage actually.
I was just actually at an idol live.
Aim doko.
I don't know, you don't have to aim in Doom.
That's what Doom, if Doom has taught me anything, you don't
have to aim.
Doom is automatic aim bot.
It's great.
Rocket launcher.
How many guns are you able to carry?
Right now I have eight, I believe.
I need them both.
If I watch the idol show...
Oh, maybe they go down if I press the buttons.
You can just point and shoot.
Point and shoot, man.
Oh.
Hmm.
Maybe I have to...
I'm scared.
There are...
order.
Take that.
I have all the rockets I need.
Maybe if I do it from...
Oh, oh, this one.
I forgot I had that.
No, I have no more bullets!
I have no regular bullets.
Maybe if I do.
I still can't reach the blueberry.
How do I change to the other?
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Right?
Okay.
Blueberry, blueberry.
Blueberry?
Blue.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Hi.
Hey.
Get me out of here.
All spared up and ready to go.
Exactly.
I'm going to save the game.
I'm scared of this level already.
I don't...
I don't trust it at all.
I don't trust this level.
I need more regular bullets.
Which one did I choose?
Wait, where do I go?
I pressed a button.
Opened up something.
Oh!
A portal!
Box the bullets!
Oh, we're back here.
How curious.
More bullets?
Bullets.
Many bullets.
Necessary.
Health.
Shotgun.
Take it.
I'll take it.
I'll take everything.
Oh.
What do you think are gonna come flying out of there?
I did not expect arrows!
I thought it was going to be little skulls.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Stop walking!
Oh my god.
Oh!
I walked right into it.
Can you please hit once?
Can you?
I just...
Can you...
Oh my gosh, I'm not anticipating.
Oh, I got him.
That was exciting.
Oh, I went berserkle.
Okay, it actually stopped.
Wow.
Aim doko.
Aim...
Gosh, I wish I had a middle finger asset right now.
Okay.
So I could say aim Coco and then give you a shiny bird.
Next outfit.
Speaking of outfits, you guys like Doki's new skin suit?
Where?
Oh, I remember where the red key was for.
I can't believe she threw away the eye patch option.
What an idiot.
Did I go through here?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
wait.
I do want that.
Um, I think I'm in trouble.
Maybe the Lynn fight.
Maybe not.
Why do you have to leave?
Come on.
Come here.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was not a good idea.
You guys don't.
Don't do that.
That was not a good idea.
She's Patako just like you now.
She's actually medium, which is quite premium.
Why did I even hit?
I thought I was aiming at him.
Oh my gosh.
The rockets are coming back again even.
Ah!
Again?
I'm getting sick of this nonsense.
Mint, are you for real?
What are you talking about?
What did I say?
What did I do?
I'm always real.
I'm keeping it real.
I'm always keeping it real.
Smash your pass for the Doom demons.
Let's go.
If that's too deviant, what's FMK?
Wait.
We went this way, right?
So now we go to the red.
Oh goodness, gracious.
Leave me alone.
Oh, Frick Merry Kill.
For the doomed humans.
Oh, I wish I could have gotten another berry.
No, no, no, no.
Oh well.
Let's see.
Mmm.
Kill...
All the little baby demons.
Frick the spider monster.
Mary Pinky.
Blood keep.
Oh, kill the lost souls.
Yes!
Kill the lost souls!
Kill the lost souls.
Mary Pinky is the right choice.
Isn't it?
Just feels right.
Feels right.
Yes, save.
Okay.
Oh.
There's lots of...
What's it called?
Oh, where did you come from?
For real!
I'm always getting shot by those guys.
Can I kill more than one thing?
It's my...
It's my frick merry kill.
I can kill whoever I want.
No, I don't want to go outside yet.
Uh, is this a door?
Oh.
Where did you come from?
You're medium, but Doki is now clearly flat as a board.
When she was, like, wait for the...
Whatever, the...
I really thought she was gonna, um...
Ouch!
Oh my goodness.
There's a lot going on here.
Okay, hold on.
Ow, death, death, death, death.
Hey, death, death.
I'm just doing circles.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I walked right into it.
I think I'm gonna die.
For realsies.
Oh my god.
Was that a lost soul?
Was that a...
Oh, no, it's just a regular.
I'm sick of these fellas.
Ouch!
I'm getting stuck on the tree!
Leave me alone!
Why won't you die?
There, I got one at least.
Goodness gracious!
What was I saying?
Oh, when she said, wait for the...
I can't even think of the word, the reference sheet.
I really thought.
She was just baiting us the whole time.
Well, she was like, wait for the reference sheet, you guys.
You'll change your mind.
Oh, they're all spawning.
That's what's happening.
Yeah.
I really thought, though, that she meant it.
Who's in there?
Can't even reach it.
She baited us.
But I think it's really cute.
Really cute outfit.
So, I'm good.
It made me think I was like, you know.
It's obviously very different.
There probably will be people who are like.
Oh.
It's such a big change, you know.
Where are you?
Where?
Made me think like, you know, if I were to...
Oh my gosh, I don't know if I would ever change.
If like, you know...
If you guys would be okay with it.
I'm like trying to snipe with a damn...
The damn shotgun.
It did from Mint 1.0.
Well, I mean, like, if I say, like, a different mama or
something, I don't know, is what I meant.
Trying to get this guy.
Did I get him?
Did he die?
Please, leave me alone!
They're just jealous of my intact bumhole.
Oh my goodness.
Leave me alone!
Oh, there he is.
He blends in with the dark.
Oh.
You guys know what I mean?
It's because they all have, you know, they all, they're all,
all their little bombs are, are, you know, you know.
I need a red kit.
What's in here?
Oh.
I'm not a friend.
A foe.
Stop saying bomb.
What else should I...
How else should I address it?
I don't even know where I am.
I'm so lost.
Oh.
I'm so lost, you guys.
Gaping hole.
Did I just do something?
Oh, I need the blue key.
I'm so lost.
right now okay red key blue key is that red or yellow that's
like kind of orange ish right derrier
take that where can i get all anything though box of rockets
this seems like uh this seems like a door Yeah!
Oh!
Look at that!
What did I get?
What did I do?
Huh?
Okay.
I'm going berserk!
Mm-hmm.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, thank you.
Oh, oh, oh.
Interesting.
Okay, I don't know what the hell is going on.
Ah!
Why?
Why are you in the library?
You don't look like you read.
Tale as old as time.
Song as old as rhyme.
Beauty and the...
Oh, okay, I have to open that.
Beast.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
You're right.
I was literally telling that to people earlier.
Not earlier, but like...
I was like, hey.
can't judge this.
You don't even know what it's... Oh, okay, here's a yellow.
But where's the yellow key?
I don't even know where it's at.
And we gotta get... Oh, there's the blue key.
Oh, I go in here.
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
Oh my god!
They're so blue!
Have to be a proper demon.
Demons are often teachers.
Oh my goodness.
I can barely And their things are faster.
Hey, hey.
Come out, dummy.
Where am I?
Where's the key?
Oh, what's this?
Run!
Blueberry!
Oh my god, oh my god.
We're fine.
Key, doko.
He... Coco!
Ahsoko!
Not Coco.
Ahsoko.
Coco.
Coco-soko!
Ahsoko!
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm gonna die!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die for real.
I'm gonna die for real.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
I just got the blueberry!
Don't do this to me!
You rude!
You're so rude!
No, I just got the blueberry.
I just got it.
Ah, koko, shoko, ah, shoko.
What's over here anyway?
A blue door.
Oh, I can't go through that.
That's probably the exit, right?
They're abusing the lost souls in this, I swear.
I swear!
Easy come, easy go.
I'll never have a blueberry again.
I'll never get one again, you guys.
What's in here?
This seems pretty.
Oh!
Ow!
Ah!
Okay.
The spicy water.
Ooy!
Oh my god.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
Oh no.
I think I'm gonna be...
I think I'm gonna be in trouble here.
Nothing sus about this room.
Absolutely not.
It doesn't look like the ceilings were calmed down any
second to try and crush me.
You know what?
I'm just gonna run for it.
Ah!
Remember if you're lost in doom, unlike real life, if people
are trying to kill you, you?
You're going the right way.
What about the other side, though?
Oh, Loki!
What did I just open?
Okay.
Oh, I think it's just a rocket launcher.
Okay, here we go.
Run!
Easy, man.
Minto Gaming.
Minto Always Gaming!
always gaming!
How do I get this way?
Not even a problem.
I have to be better about not being so hesitant.
But also, you know, I'm such a cautious gamer.
Such a cautious... Maybe not even a gamer.
I'm a cautious person.
I'm a cautious ghost.
I've died once.
I don't want to die again, you know what I mean?
Did I everything in here this feels like so something's got
it was yellow i don't want to die again so i just am
cautious about where i go and what i'm doing anyway
dang he's just throwing them we interrupted the class
everybody pinky your husband no
Ah!
Also, what's that over there?
Interesting.
Where are you?
Oh my god, I didn't see him at all.
Gosh, this level is pretty long.
Oh my god, there's two of them.
Oh, never mind.
Nice, so.
This level's pretty.
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, what did I just summon?
What did I just summon?
What's this?
Library's pretty stylish, though.
It actually is very nice, right?
Okay, nice.
Uh, maybe this, actually.
Hey, muscles!
I hate you!
You are the pain of our existence!
Yeah, dummy, bozo, idiot, stupid, ugly, meatball!
Ah!
I opened something.
It's okay, you're allowed to bully these guys, okay?
Gosh.
How do I get that thing over there?
I'm so curious.
Sure.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Thanks for the super- Oh, shut.
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe I open like this?
Okay.
Oh, come on!
There's something else I need to do.
Oh, I think I did it.
I think I did it.
No!
So unfair, I was right here!
Will you play other boomer shooters in the future?
I'd like to, yeah.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come
on, gotta be quicker.
It's...
Oh, they got the gun.
Nice, nice.
We got the plasma gun.
Which is good mostly to get...
So this isn't a door.
Interesting.
Okay.
It's good mostly to get ammo and stuff for it, right?
Now where do I go from here?
Wait!
Anything open up in here?
I think I'm lost.
I think I don't know where to go.
I think I'm stuck.
This is where we started, right?
Why did I just open?
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
No.
Oh, there's lots of armor here.
I'll take that.
The map?
Go right of the blue door.
Okay, let me grab all this stuff first.
right of the blue door.
Oh, what's this?
Huh?
Oh!
Yui!
Wait, how do I get to the blue door?
Hmm, I think I went the wrong way.
What is this map?
Demons have no architectural sense at all.
Over here?
Oh, up here?
Maybe?
Ah!
Thank you.
But also, No, thank you.
We're just gonna blow them up.
Nice.
We just blew them up.
I like how it gives you more shotgun shells because they're
like, obviously you used your shotgun here.
Oh, gosh.
It's gonna be more lost souls, please.
Again, I'm too... I don't trust it.
I should be absolutely nothing.
I knew it!
I... I knew it!
Where am I going?
Wait, I'm not that way!
This is so unfair!
No!
I'm so glad I saved.
I am so glad...
I saved!
I am so glad I saved!
Can you imagine?
You just had to stand there.
Ugh!
Oh my god, ABS always be saving, so true.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, I have to run through here.
Okay, okay.
Oh!
Do you think they ever just let that Arachnitron in the cage
out for walks or does it just stay in there all day?
I think he just stays in there all.
I think nobody wants to touch him.
Thank you guys.
Welcome back to membership.
Thank you.
100, 100, 100.
Let's go.
Watch your...
Uh-oh.
Entering watch your step.
What do you mean by that?
Was this last level a hint at what's to come?
Hello?
Plasma gun immediately?
That's a little frightening.
It's worrisome, don't you think?
It's a little scary to think about.
Why are they giving me that immediately?
Upon starting.
types of guns here, actually.
Okay.
A berserk.
I'll take it.
There's everything.
That's not a good sign.
Oh, thank you.
Wait.
No, no, no, no.
Save, save, save, yes, thank you.
I think they're trying to tell you something.
I think so, too.
Okay.
That reminds me, aren't you also a lost soul since you're a
ghost?
You might fit right in with them.
That might be why they're so obsessed with me.
I'm probably like famous in this world, you know?
They're like, whoa.
In Phantom, the lost soul.
The ghostest with the mostest.
Uh oh, I heard them.
I heard them come in.
I heard them.
Where are you?
Not here?
The music is, like, even more scary.
Oh, there's the exit right there!
Okay.
Good to know?
This is their weapon museum, and they're going to be very
angry.
You're stealing all the exhibits!
Maybe they're just like...
One guy is just like, them behind oh boy we should be
keeping why is they giving me everything this is really
scary wait this is actually so bad he's like I told you we
should be keeping them behind glass oh there's a white berry
oh okay
I can't fall into the red either right oh my god is he
asleep in there or what's going on Why isn't he moving?
Hello?
Ah!
Wait, hold on!
There's something wrong with him!
Hello?
I need a blue key.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, I got a blue key.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, there's two of them.
Oh gosh, there's like five of them.
Oh gosh, there's like so many of them!
Oh god, I suck!
I suck!
Allow
them for two seconds!
Blueberry...
I know this is like overkill, but...
Oh my gosh, I'm just trying to get rid of some of them.
Please.
Okay, BFG?
Wait, oh, let's go with this one instead.
The un...
Oh, uh...
Wait, hold on, let me think about this one.
I made a mistake before.
There we go, now I got on both of the ones.
Uh, the un...
Life...
Unmaker.
Unmaker!
Hey!
Where did you even come from?
I thought I took them all out.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
Oh goodness gracious.
Is this guy awake yet?
Or...
We're just gonna leave him at that.
I think we'll just let him have his little nap and not even
worry about it.
Mm-hmm.
I want all this stuff.
I guess we can go inside.
Yeah, he's just chilling.
What if I...
Oh, this is the best option, I'd say.
He has hair!
What?
What just spawned in?
What just spawned in this time?
Oh, okay, just you.
I can't believe he has hair!
It's like really long too!
What is this decoration?
It's like really long.
Oh, I just realized I've been blocking my armor.
Let me scoot over a little bit.
Or I'll go here.
Sorry, it's always hard to find where to go.
Bald, bald, bald!
Ohio mint, hi!
Thank you!
Thank you for the don't know.
Wait, who would win the strongest minty ghost mate or the
weakest Brazilian male with RGB night?
Um, well isn't Sam the weakest Brazilian or something,
something?
So...
Oh, hold on.
Dang it, I really thought that was a door.
Are you sure?
Okay, here we go.
What the?
Invisible guy.
Ah!
Punch him!
Oh, okay, bye.
It was all in my head.
Okay.
Cool.
I imagine that.
Nice.
Oh, wait, no, that's not what I wanted to do.
I want to check if this is...
One of these are going to be a door.
One of them has to be.
Where am I now?
I can't...
I don't even know.
Where am I at?
Ah!
Blue...
Blue armor!
Not Blueberry.
Take your meds, Minto.
I'm trying.
Oh, lassoes!
They're all doors.
They're just locked.
Do we hear anything else?
Now how?
Does this open anything else?
Or...
Doesn't sound like it.
Where do I go from here?
Weird.
I go from here so many voices whisper in wire which is the
book sorry it's from Pocahontas 2 which is like the most
insulting movie I think I've ever seen in my entire life
actually though where do I go I think I messed up the order
okay hold on there was some place okay so we know that this
one goes down and then it goes back up and then we i don't
even know where i'm at here though oh dang it come on let me
up up ease thank you oh where am i
who oh come on there's a sequel oh yes There's a sequel and
it's all about...
Okay, so you know how like the actual history of Pocahontas?
Like, okay, well, it's actually...
I mean, the actual history is like pretty dark.
But I mean, like, I don't think she ever...
Like, John Smith was not who she married.
It was like some other guy.
And so in Pocahontas 2...
In Pocahontas 2, basically they were like, maybe we should
be more historically accurate.
And they...
They kill off...
Sorry for spoilers.
kill off John Smith but not really and then they get her
married to that guy that she oh oh dang to the guy that was
the real guy in history I'm actually so lost if anybody at
back theaters know what to do I don't know what to do um but
then he wasn't dead and he comes back and he's just like you
know what
what is it he's like you know what it's fine you can go be
with that new guy that's just very awful it's like they
almost it's like it's we do this every time does something
go up here or what am I missing oh
Historical NTR.
Kind of.
Confusingly, she marries a guy named John Rolf.
And not the guy named... Yes!
Yes!
John Rolf!
Check the map.
Uh...
Wait, uh, Q.
I guess there's nothing else here.
Unless I want to get the...
The...
This stuff.
Unless I want to get the health bonuses i guess okay let's
go back to the beginning then let's go back outside there's
probably like a whole army waiting for me like how do i get
in there hmm but yeah that's just like such a mess it's just
such a mess pocahontas too
it's a bunch of losers it's a bunch of tiny demons wait oh
oh they're cycling through i'm noticing they're going
through like the easiest to the hardest oh my god oh my god
i knew it i knew it i knew it i knew it why did you spot on
top of me though you jerk next should be oh okay Why is
infighting?
He hits you in the back.
I need to be careful not to get trapped on the things here.
Oh my goodness.
I don't want to waste all my...
Oh.
Wow.
fast.
No,
I should be able to get him.
Who's next?
Oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh,
oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh,
God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God,
oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god, there's a second one.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Instant karma.
What are you talking about, karma?
How is it, karma?
What did I do?
Okay, nice.
They actually don't take that many hits.
Which is great.
Can I get another blueberry?
I got a stem pack.
Oh my god.
Oh, no!
What is this guy?
Oh, oh.
Which is the BFG?
BFG!
The cyber demon!
Yes, the cyber demon.
Guys, I died.
Where did I save last?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm really far behind.
Oh gosh, oh no, oh no, oh no, I really messed up you guys.
Have you ever tried avoiding the rockets?
That's a really good idea.
Let's see, maybe if we just rocket punch through everything.
Oh, we don't need to rocket punch through these guys.
Oh.
Oh, like this guy could use a rocket punch.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Where's the other guy?
Here, are you?
Oh, no, there's some loss.
Oh, they're infighting!
Yeah, take care of them!
Yeah, those guys suck!
Wait, no, no, no, no, no.
Take care of them for me, please.
Oh, that opens up a whole new can of everything.
Oh, I don't know where I'm aiming, but...
Ow!
Why did I do that?
Why did I...
I'm just gonna restart.
Why did I do that?
Why did I think that that would work?
Oh, goodness.
Okay, this is a bit of a... Okay, this is probably the most
trouble I've had.
in this so far, which is fine, because so far it hasn't been
so bad.
I mean, I know I'm playing on, like, you know, not super
hard, but whatever.
It's fine.
Why am I...
Oh, wait, okay.
Look at them just phasing into existence.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Calm down, buddy.
Can I touch the Ren?
Will I die?
Oh, why don't you in fight?
Go after him, he hit you!
It's rude as hell.
Okay, let's kill everything before we grab the key.
I'm hearing...
Try walking on the Ren.
I think we're safe.
Okay, cool.
Oh, whoa.
Where'd you come from?
I didn't get the key yet.
I don't even get the key yet.
Please.
Oh my god.
This is not good.
oh my god oh my god i'm gonna i'm gonna die here for real
i'm gonna die here for real oh god please
yeah i use the bfg for this bit oh my gosh i just can't get
through it's such a tight area oh and the splash damage on
the rocket kids heck can
only come out Once I...
Once I got the key, but clearly not.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah, screw you.
Ugly.
Got them both, nice.
Oh my god, he was waiting.
He was waiting for that.
He's waited his whole life to send...
Nice, so...
Oh, that was close.
Oh my god, stop!
Stop!
Are you kidding me?
That was pretty unfair, actually.
I'm not gonna lie.
I am stuck!
How tall am I?
I'm either two feet or five!
Give me, give me a break!
Oh my god.
You got the BFG-9000, oh yes.
If only I weren't so dang slow.
Oh, they're fighting?
The boys are fighting?
The girls are fighting?
Just let them at it.
Oh, uh-oh.
I ruined their fight.
Oh, my gosh.
I didn't even see that coming at me.
Oh.
Guys, I'm not doing so hot.
What's wrong with me?
I've been playing fine this whole time.
And then suddenly, suddenly my brain goes to doo-doo.
What's happening to me?
Oh.
Need more gamer subs.
Stop.
I can't tell if there's anything still here.
There has to be.
Oh, a hero.
Oh, well, of all things, it's an invisible pinky.
Yeah, let's save.
But I will save next thing.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
There's some more.
Where are they though?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Oh my god, there's more!
Even more!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
There's even more!
Where did they all come from?
What the heck is going on?
they're just spawning in midair okay now now I think we're
in the clear okay let's save again yes oh they're no match
for you anyway I'm the doom the mint guy okay let's go shoot
this thing in here Look at his hair when he turns around.
Oh my god.
Unbelievably rude.
What the hell?
Why didn't you die when I shot you?
I'm Facebook friends with artists who did the sprites and
animations for Doom 2 and 64.
goal was to improve the sprites and animation.
Use claymation.
That's so cool.
World's strongest imp.
Clearly.
Oh my god.
What an absolute...
What is this buffoonery?
I'm trying to move it.
It just cannot.
Okay.
They're all gone.
I come here.
And then some guy's gonna spawn over here.
Wait.
Hello?
Doom guy.
Why couldn't you?
He's right in front of you.
Okay.
That's actually how I truly feel right now in this moment.
It's like what I actually want to do to them.
Just want to punch them in the face.
Is there any more?
Is that it?
We get it out of our system?
Oh goodness gracious.
Oh yeah yeah.
This way.
Oh!
Ah!
I lost so much health from...
I was at a hundred.
And that one...
Oh my goodness.
That one shot from that...
Heckin' grunt...
Made me lose so much.
Hello?
Where are you?
Oh.
Okay, well there's health and stuff we can grab in here.
So we'll at least do that.
Uh, how do I...
Oh, here.
That's how we get up.
I'm gonna grab the health.
And then we'll...
Like, it's here.
Yeah.
Grab this.
Shotgun guys are so deadly.
I know, I lose so much health to them all the time.
Go to...
I'm lost.
So we went to this one.
We're gonna go to this one.
Most of the BFG's damage comes from a shotgun-like spray of
tracers coming from the player.
Oh, really?
Oh, dang it.
Oh, I'm at max armor anyway.
You know what?
I think it's fine.
Sorry, I'm gonna be save scumming here a little bit.
The BFG tracer is only fire when the projectile hits
something.
Okay.
So they need to be in sight.
That's so inconvenient.
So first we got our little guys.
Did I...
Did I take a hit?
I can't tell if I did or not.
We're about to get to a cyber demon.
Our first cyber demon, baby.
Oh, imps.
Imps.
Wait, there's still a pinky!
Okay.
Yeah, take that.
Take that.
Take- oh, aim, don't go.
Take- oh, aim.
Oh my god, ouchy, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh!
I don't know about you!
I'm not feeling so good.
Do I even have time to BFG them?
I'm just running!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I think I got him.
I think I got him, but...
I don't even know!
There we go!
Nice!
Just run and shoot!
Run and shoot!
That's all I can do!
Wee!
Wow!
Ah!
Cyber demon?
Where'd he go?
Where is he?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I'm at two healths in a dream!
I'm not gonna make it, you guys!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I'm not gonna make it!
Where's the health?
Stimps?
Where's the simp packs!
Use the unburther?
I'm sorry, unmaker?
Oh my god.
Juke's.
Juke's, like, we've never seen them before!
If I make it out of this.
I got an achievement!
Kill a cyber demon!
2 HP and I dream, everybody.
The dream is real.
Maybe.
Let's go!
Thank you for super chat thank you oh it's open wait if i
walk in here am i gonna die
greg does have one regret regarding doom 64 the cyber demons
horns look like dog ears like it did look kind of cute
it saved right just in case okay um
Exit.
Wait, but what was the other spot?
Wait a second.
Hold on.
One moment, please.
I want to see what was in the other area.
Oh!
How do I get to the blueberry?
How do I get to this blueberry then?
It's clearly through here.
Or the whiteberry, yeah.
The pearl.
How do I get this thing?
Just jump.
Math, let's see.
Yeah, it's behind that door, but I don't know how to open
it.
Hmm.
that well I'm curious very curious rocket the door yes I'll
punch it
is it working hmm what does it give me anyway does it give
me health or is that a lost cause at this point oh oh
actually it's a good thing we came back in here there is
some health wait there's some health packs you guys wait
this actually might be good before we go to the next level
because otherwise i'm doomed wait get me up no how do i get
up how do i get up oh i think i have to run from here
Hmm.
Interesting.
Thought the yellow one was invincibility.
Oh, it might be.
Gosh, I would have really loved to have that.
Like, how do I get the thing?
Ay, ay, ay, ay.
Oh, hello, hello, hello, hello, let's, oh, let's grab them
armor or not.
Wait, wait, wait, okay.
Oh, huh.
Stop, please.
It's so sensitive.
Nice.
Okay, got some armor.
Invulnerability is green.
Ah, so you guys were all wrong.
Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Okay, now there's that one, which is health, which I
desperately need.
I know I'm like, I could leave.
I could just go to the next thing.
But I just am so desperate for health right now.
I'm so desperate for health right now.
Oh, come on, please.
It's right there.
Just grab it.
Grab it, Doomguy.
Grab it.
And you too.
Why won't you let me have you?
How do I get to this?
So...
You know what, screw it.
Let's just go.
I'm done.
Oh wait, I just went the long way, but...
It's fine.
Help!
I need the simp packs.
Spawned for you.
I'm very fearful.
The first couple of levels were like a walk in the park and
now suddenly...
I'm feeling it, Mr. Crabbs.
Oh, shoot.
Since when?
What hands do you have?
Mr. Skull!
Oh my goodness, oh my goodness!
I just slid down the door.
I don't even... Oh, hello!
I didn't mean to.
I can't take a single hit, you guys, or else I'm so done.
Oh, there's a health pack right there!
Who's yelling?
Ah!
Whoo!
Such a lust for revenge!
Wait, actually, who...
Where did that shot come from?
Is that a guy in there?
No, that's a flame.
Hidden wall.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I caught up.
blueberry oh my gosh we got a blueberry oh my gosh we got a
blueberry okay I could save the game now we can go over fake
wall oh fake wall my beloved that's the exit right there
okay I'm full let's go down here
Is this all a door?
No.
Are those gonna yell at me?
Are those gonna shoot at me?
Oh.
Dang.
I got a secret area, though.
I guess I'll, um, remember that for when we need more!
More simpax.
What is in there?
Oh.
Just a decoration.
Gosh, they're...
Their decoration...
The interior design is so unique!
I hate the shotgun!
I hate the...
Blueberry!
It's
walking the ghouls!
You show off.
Just walk in the goo, you show off.
Oh, the goo is gone.
What a strange room.
I need a red key.
I'm gonna change to this.
Okay.
Curious.
Thank you very much.
I hate lost souls.
actually i think they are truly my least favorite are these
oh wait this one oh i thought those were things we could
shoot oh hello whoa wait wow
i like this room oh um okay uh huh
Hmm.
I thought that maybe this would trigger it.
Try when you're on a step.
Go, go, go, go.
Yay!
Thank you.
What was I gonna say?
I knew that there was something important about that step.
More than just being a little step stool.
Wait, can we...
also shoot the other ones then no these ones are boring and
don't matter
sharp shooter don't you know it i'm being really paranoid
right now because of any loss oh oh it's so good to be
paranoid i love being paranoid
this is why we're paranoid everybody has been played doom at
16 slash eternal i have not not yet
yellow key have i even gone down here box of bullets i have
not
i saw one in there one more Nope.
Oh, two more.
I love the way they mumble.
That.
Gremlin noises.
Oh, wow.
That's a lot of them.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I'm not about to die here.
Wait, are these the stronger guys?
Or the, I guess there's the stronger guys.
Because, uh, still not dead.
There we go.
Kinole!
Pack pack!
Take that.
Kinolees are tasty.
Indeed they are.
Was that everything here?
Wait, this is the spot that...
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go down.
Let's go into this room.
Oh, it's...
He was waiting.
He was camping me right there.
I know I...
It's so hard to see the guys in here.
I think I got all of them.
For real?
I hate this game.
I hate this game!
I hate this game so...
so...
much.
I hate this game.
Oh my god.
Skill issue!
Go, go!
Oh, no, no.
I said go, go, but I didn't think it would be like this.
Oh, no!
I can't see anything.
I got a health pack though.
I could see that at least.
Uh-oh.
As soon as I turn on this light, it's gonna be hell on
earth.
Huh.
I mean, it's already...
It's already hell.
Oh.
Maybe not?
Yes, maybe yes.
If you really want to prove your boomer minto bonafides and
try playing blood next if you dare.
I think I have not proved myself.
What?
Who am I trying to prove to anyway, huh?
Huh?
Oh, you must prove yourself to be.
Oh my gosh, I see him up there with his long, luscious hair.
gonna come down you coward what the hell what took you so
long oh my god i just ran right into that
oh please oh my god ouchy ouch ouch ouch i'm stuck on the
stairs oh my gosh oh the stairs saved me
10 hp in a dream I feel like I'm not gonna make it you guys
I almost even fell into the pits of
45 hp that's not as bad but you know
how much of how much oh 500 that's not so bad you can do it
you really think so you really think You really, really,
really think so!
My armor's at 7.
Secret.
Oh,
I don't have to go back through the main area.
Maybe this game is sometimes really nice.
Well, really is an exaggeration, but...
This game is kind.
This game has its kind moments.
That's a better way to put it.
Now...
Wait.
You need a yellow key.
Oh, I just grabbed a red key.
I thought I grabbed the yellow key.
Wait, where was the red area?
Through here?
There was?
I'm gonna save it.
Sorry.
Save's coming.
A little bit.
Okay.
Say god.
What the?
What did I just hear?
Just heard someone.
Oh, hero.
my god
wait i'm trapped in a corner wait i'm trapped in a corner
please please it was me
that didn't even mean i meant to press not or eight okay
load i love saves coming
There we go.
We'll be prepared.
Is it overkill?
I don't think so.
I just died, so you know.
Lampy, welcome.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Very much.
I have lots of ammo, and they give me more right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait a second.
Do you see that?
Interesting.
Wow, what a really cool room.
Oh.
Excuse me, can I get this armor, please?
Leave me alone.
Thank you.
Are you gonna play Uma Musume Global?
I would love to.
I'm scared, though, because I'm really bad about...
Oh my gosh, there's so much going on here.
I'm really bad about playing more than one.
Ah!
One mobile game!
Oh.
Once!
Ah!
This was the worst mistake of my life.
Please die.
I know there's one more.
I heard him.
I saw him.
He went that way.
Oh!
But yeah, I'm really bad about playing.
Like, I kind of put all my focus into one mobile game.
And I, like...
I don't know.
Because I...
Just kind of...
I don't know.
Maybe it's like an attention thing, you know.
It's like hard for me to focus on more than one.
Oh!
There's a blueberry!
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Where'd you go?
There you are.
I hear an... Oh, hello.
Where the hell did you come from?
suit your hair oh my god let's um nah wait yeah let's just
take him out and then no oh wait where are they souls
looking for some lost souls
Oh my
god.
I didn't think it would reach through here.
Bring IMAX here.
Really?
I'm so afraid of my favorite stuff coming over.
Like, I love Blue Archive.
I try not to spend too much money on it.
I think I'm usually pretty okay.
I'm usually pretty good.
About spending.
like
Overkill but that's okay
Oh my god no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no Please
Where are you?
I'm trying to speak to my chat could you all stop for five
seconds anyway what was i saying no ammo i spend um maybe
like 10 less than 10 a month they have like a special month
pack
so i spend like and i did that oh oh oh goodness oh my god
one he just came out of nowhere i hear another one i don't
know what i hear
what did i just touch monthly pa fun stop it's just it's
tough to like get you more jemmies um but i never spend like
on the themselves, you know.
Ow!
Nice.
I'm typically pretty good with gotcha stuff.
I'm pretty good about not...
Oh wait, this is where we came from, about not spending such
an insane amount.
Because also, I would feel so guilty.
I think...
In that like...
Wait, huh?
Go down?
Oh!
I would feel guilty in that...
Gameplay is not for me in Blue Archive?
That's okay, I think.
I'd rather spend money on cute Derpy Yoshi.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die in here.
Wait, I'm gonna die in here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Please!
Oh my gosh.
I would feel guilty because, you know, if I got my money
through, like, a conventional means, then I wouldn't feel
guilty.
But I don't.
And so I feel like it's a waste of the money I do receive
from you guys.
So that's why I'm...
Try to be even more cautious and careful about it.
Because, yeah.
It's your allowance?
No!
But I bought...
Okay, but I bought a bunch of Metal Gear stuff.
I messaged Maddie.
Who she does Metal Gear comics.
Oh, that's Raspberry.
I messaged her because I was on Mercari.
And I was looking and I found...
What is this?
Oh, my eyes!
Oh, wait.
If I have this, please let me in.
Where do I go with the radiation shield?
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me in, let me in.
Um, hold on.
Um.
They... I've been looking for this figure for such a long
time, and it's a Metal Gear Solid Force Snake.
Like, old Snake, and His ass is just really, really fat in
the figure.
So I've been looking for it, and I found it.
And I was like, Maddie, I found the figure.
It finally came up on Mercari.
And she was like, yippee!
And sent me a bunch of big butt snake emotes.
Anyway, where am I supposed to go?
Oh, wait, no.
I don't think I'm supposed to go back to the acid room.
go down where the poison floor is what's the poison floor
wait like that one room or the room the floor wasn't poison
though it was on fire snake with a fat dumpy buttons thank
you he's like he's like in the in the pose you know where
he's like you know his he looks kind of like spider-man but
his ass is just really really really big the red lava has
progress the one over here oh I think I think I see what you
mean oh oh no I wasted it oh oh am I gonna be okay I don't
even know where it is this room this here I have to do all
of this wait no I don't have to do it all over again there
was an entrance oh there was an entrance oh wait do I have
to Do this all over again.
The yellow pillars.
You guys, I can't get it.
My bad.
Oh my god.
No!
Lappy, thanks for the gift.
Dude!
Yeah!
What's your favorite?
Oh, who are your favorite Blue Archive characters?
I love Cherino.
I love Koharu.
I love Shiroko.
I love...
Arona.
I love Arona.
Check for a switch.
Oh, that's a good idea.
Yeah, I don't see one right here.
I think it's just a skill issue.
Yeah!
See?
That was just a skill issue after all.
Oh, come on, man.
Let me at least heal.
Oh, there's courses.
There's two of them.
You freaks travel in packs.
You're just like girls who have to go to the bathroom.
You can never be by yourself.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, no.
I'm not even hitting him.
Oh, whoa.
How did I miss that?
Can you just die already?
I thought he was going to be dead after that hit.
Okay.
I need some health.
We finally have our yellow key.
Which means we can finally get to the exit.
Switch to the good shotgun.
Wait, what are you talking about?
Was I on the bad shot?
No, I was on the shotgun?
I was on the good shotgun.
Shut up, mod.
So it's not the super shotgun!
Oh, I switched to it on accident.
Okay.
Alright, let's get out of here.
I'm gonna be paranoid on the way back.
Paranoid, I'm paranoid!
I'm paranoid!
I'm so glad I'm paranoid.
Oh, they're all gone.
I thought
something opened.
Oh my god, no way.
No way.
Get me out of this, please.
I never asked to be the Doom guy, please.
I never asked to be the Doom guy!
There's a secret exit.
Where are you at?
In here?
Wait, hold on.
Am I hearing a...
Oh, is that a door?
Is that I'm hearing?
Ah!
Wait a second!
I got it, I got it, I got it.
I don't know.
Is that it?
Okay, that might be it.
Come on!
Okay, hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
Run, run, run, run, run!
No!
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Please, please, please.
Secret!
Oh.
That was the secret.
80% secret.
30 minutes Oh my gosh In the void Oh You wretch as a strange
Asrid Asrid Asrid Odor assaults you Death and demon carcass
No nightmare could have prepared you for this You realize
that this place was not meant for living humans Acrid Acrid
Acrid What sound does a C make?
Okay, then how do you pronounce acid?
Dummy!
English language is hard!
Oh my god!
Wowie!
They just throw you straight in, baby.
Okay, no more time for baby games anymore.
We're in the home stretch, you guys.
This is it.
This is the home stretch.
Can I have some health at least, though?
Like, for real?
Okay.
Like a blueberry would be so appreciated.
Okay, save the game.
Now that we're here, level 9.
31?
Huh?
Wait, hmm?
Hmm?
Lampy, thanks for the gifted!
What was it?
Can you guys shut up in here?
Okay, whoa, this place is crazy looking.
Oh, um, excuse you!
Oh my god.
Ah!
I do...
Hold on, I'm gonna load.
I'm just gonna restart.
That's okay.
It's okay.
I'll just restart.
In fact, I'm just gonna...
Leave me alone.
Uglies.
Okay, anyway.
Oof.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Is this a mazer?
Oh, my God.
I can see there's, like, they're shooting at me from so, so
far away.
Well, there's the exit.
Humans are not supposed to be here.
I think I made a mistake.
Ah!
Oh, my gosh.
Jump scare.
That's the sound I make too whenever I hear you.
I hear you and see your ugly face.
I go, Ah!
Ah!
Yeah, take that.
That guy wasn't even walking.
He was just literally sliding.
Let's bring back memories of the Star Wars Dark Forces game
and Jedi Knight games.
Those were classics.
I've never played those.
Well, I wouldn't have played something that's Star Wars.
It's not really my thing.
Did you know that there's actually a Doom game?
Of...
Wait.
Oh, I thought I said that.
saw there's a doom game of of cereal what
the hell is in here
i'm so glad i came in here with the blueberry i need a blue
key where is it coming from the checks game yes yes i think
that's the one
These guys are just gonna keep respawning.
Need a yellow key.
This is all a little confusing.
But we'll get it.
We'll get there.
Would you play it?
Sure, why not?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh god!
I
think I got him though, nice.
Where is he?
Where are you going?
Oh my god.
Oh I can't believe I dodged that.
Where are you going?
Okay.
Also a Christian Doom game on Noah's Ark.
What?
That sounds awesome.
Save the game real quick.
matrix dodge there.
That's called being a Toho player.
That's called playing Toho one time in your life.
How do I get here?
Hmm.
There's so much stuff going on around here.
Oh, we got the red key.
Nice.
Is this a secret level i think so because it says level 31
and but aren't there only like
technically sorry i'm scared of this whatever is going on
here by the way guys my meeting is at 11 30 if you could
just help me um if you could help me uh it if I stay here
too late.
Oh, hello.
No, not that.
Okay.
Any more?
Any more.
Time zones, though.
Well, right now it's 9.17 for me.
What's down here?
How long is that?
I think it's a couple hours.
Who's down there?
Who is that?
A baron of hell.
Sorry, that's me.
I just shot you.
I just sent you to an early grave.
Or maybe it's a properly timed grave.
Who knows?
Okay, we got the blue.
Which means we can go get whatever the heck that thing was.
Which was...
Here, here.
Oh, I keep forgetting that I have.
Right here.
Oh.
Oh, no!
What are you?
What?
What is this thing?
Why won't you...
Why won't you let me have you?
Also, I cannot get over the fact that, like...
demons in hell have to like they can't even finish their
bridges are they so stupid they don't know how to build
you'll need that it powers up the unmaker okay we'll have to
come back for it wait but where else can I go with the blue
but I flip some sort of switch so maybe
is this Aha, aha, aha.
Oh, oh, oh, I didn't realize it was...
Okay, no worries.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, too fast.
Just kidding.
This honestly looks like a nether build.
Because of the colors.
I can see it.
What if I go across when it's...
Oh, there we go.
Okay, never mind.
We never needed it after all.
Okay, what other yellow places could we go?
What better way to spend your birthday than watching your
kamioshi playing one of the games that made most of your
childhood?
Oh, shawood, y'all!
Oh, my gosh.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear shoot y'all Happy birthday to you
Happy birthday I feel like it's been a while since I've seen
you I hope you're doing well Unless you've been around and
I'm just blind I'm really sorry Wait won't you come down
Come down, little hell baby.
Hmm, wall button.
I already pressed it.
It opened up something else.
See?
No.
Hmm, it's not the wall button, but maybe another wall
button.
It's like, we're kind of hard to finish bridges when some
doom guy keeps killing your workforce.
They're just like...
Everyone here, all like the pinkies and stuff, are actually
being like, Hey, man, you shouldn't be here.
This place is really dangerous.
It's still under construction.
Hey, man, you need to wear a hard hat.
And we're just like, Ripper J.
Oh,
screw your safety.
What was this over here?
Oh, yeah.
How do I get in through here?
Hmm.
Mysterious.
I don't want to just leave yet, though.
Oh.
Unless it's one of those, like, you walk up to it, and
that's when it comes down.
I'm not sure.
I'm looking for any other wall.
Any other wall buttons.
I don't see any, though.
Go towards the exit, not all the way until you get a quake.
Ah!
So it is exactly...
Whoops, wrong way.
It is exactly as I thought it was.
Wait, wrong way.
I was the right way.
This way.
Oh.
Run!
Wait.
Where'd I go?
What?
Huh?
Did it teleport?
Hide and seek.
Oh, maybe it was in that spot down here.
The grunts are like, hey man, it's dangerous in here.
And Doomguy is just like, yeah, it is, but not for me.
I think I...
You were too slow!
Story of my life.
Doomguy is like, actually, like, a meter tall, okay?
guys it's not his fault he's really really sure do i just
run out this the sun
100 everything the spiral
where are we at now okay yes are they your doom or are you
there, Doom.
Oh, now we're 19.
Really makes you think.
Ew.
Wait, what's goes here?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
Wow, there's a whole party in there.
Hope I'm not disrupting anything.
Let's grab this guy first.
Dang.
Who is blowing up?
Oh.
I think him your aim aim doko oh dang that really would have
hit me
here we go oh there's another one oh gosh okay hold on oh
there's several of them okay this is fine this is not fine
oh my god they're all coming here they're all coming here
in here.
I don't want to be trapped in here!
Yeah, in fight!
Oh my god.
How did I manage?
How did I live?
I don't know.
I don't know how I lived!
There we go.
Die already!
The dodge, though.
a little bit of game.
Maybe I can get them from down here.
Oh.
Doom guy just...
Infamously doesn't know how to lift up, you know?
Infamously does not know how to lift up a gun.
Oh, they're fighting?
The girls are fighting?
Oh, okay.
Now I'm fighting the girls.
Oh, shaw.
Oh!
Alrighty guys.
Oh guys.
I did it again.
That was really scary.
That was not fun.
Oops, I did it again.
With your heart, got lost.
Okay, we can kill this guy, though.
But now I know that there's a second one.
Well, there's a couple, but you know.
That guy right there.
Oh, uh-oh.
Did you notice?
You didn't notice me.
Oh, you didn't.
You noticed me.
Excuse you?
I'm in the middle of something.
thing.
Okay.
Actually, what if I just unmade it?
Unmaker!
There we go.
Time to unmake.
That's why I unmade your mother.
The girls are not biting.
Though they should be.
Phew.
We... I'm gonna save the game.
There's a nice blueberry over there.
Whose footprints are these?
what else was oh i was grabbing the armor that's what i
wanted to grab once it comes back down i don't want to oh
and there's a backpack there too even
nice nice i'll take everything that you got i'm robbing them
blind who's footprints are these did i grab this do i need
this no okay let's go hit the button and chain gun it up.
I love the projectile enemies.
They're super fun to dodge.
It feels like...
Like when I'm playing a...
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
When I'm playing a rhythm game, you know?
Fingers!
Just die already!
Why are there so many of you?
My ears!
My heckin' ears!
God, my ears.
Take it a sip.
That was crazy.
That was pretty crazy.
I didn't even get to hit the button.
I thought they came out with the button.
I was very mistaken.
I was...
But we didn't take as much damage, I guess, as we could
have, so...
Maybe a win.
This is a different area, right?
We need the red key.
I'm just gonna save one more time.
Let's go.
Okay, how much ammo do I even have?
541?
Oh, it's not bad at all.
Okay, do I need... Did I even use this?
Nope, okay.
I'm good.
Alright.
Let's go.
There was nothing in here.
Nothing opened up.
Nothing secret.
No.
Okay.
How do I get the blueberry?
How do I get the key?
How do I get everything?
Oh!
Ah!
Yippee!
Where am I?
I wish I could look down or up.
Wait, where am I?
Did I get the key?
No.
Wait.
Oh.
No fall damage.
Baby!
Oh,
he didn't die.
Wait, I missed two.
Dang.
I almost had a perfect record.
You guys ruined my streak.
Cool.
So I got the red keys.
Now we can continue onwards.
What?
Wow.
What a short episode.
I mean, the last one was really, really long.
So...
100%.
Break down.
That's me.
I'm having a break.
Yeah.
So true.
So true game.
This level?
Uh-oh.
Am I in for it?
There's an old DDR song that goes, Breakdown.
It was one of my favorites to play always.
What if I just...
Oh, I need a blue key.
Oh my god!
Did that hit me?
Yes, it did.
So sad.
No, no, no.
Ew.
Oops.
Be for you.
Oh gosh, you guys.
Do you guys remember it too?
We're so old.
We're so old you guys.
Oh, we can just kind of go up here and...
Take them down.
Two by two.
One by one is for babies.
Two by two, baby.
Why won't you die?
I'm not old.
Breaks back.
Why is the music so frightening?
How do I get down from here?
There we go.
Picked up a clip.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
I'll take it all.
Oh, that's not a blueberry at all.
Um, how?
No.
Brown...
Cow.
I'm showing too much skin to the viewers!
Huzzakashi.
No!
I'm... I'm just showing... Should I just cover my face?
I don't see anything to like push.
Except the thing that's all the way up there.
Too much exposed.
No!
Do you guys see any buttons or do you guys, have you guys
seen one?
The walls are made of flesh.
No!
Maybe the floor is made of flesh.
Shoot from afar maybe.
Let's try it.
This is
actually spooky.
Oh, from the upper level.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm not going to make it.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
Woo.
Thanks, guys, for your help.
Much appreciated.
Push, push.
Oh.
Are these bars?
She's spitting.
I thought they were gonna have dummy demons inside.
We're going down.
I'm sorry for disturbing!
Where are you?
Nice, but...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Very cool.
You're not sorry.
Yeah, I'm...
Oh, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Yo!
What's in the other one, though?
I saw two doors open.
Wait?
Wait, wait.
Secret!
So many secrets around here.
Oh, never mind.
I thought both of them opened.
Just the one did.
Okay, cool.
Let's keep going.
Sorry for disturbing you.
Shoot's rocket at your face.
It's not... It's nothing personal.
It's nothing personal.
It's nothing personal, kid.
It's just... It's just business.
It's just business, everybody.
Wait, where am I?
this uh this maze
what's gonna happen when i open
wait this way oh my goodness
maze of men only the strongest may yellow key a maze made
for only real men uh-oh what's gonna happen in here no Cool
walls.
They're pretty cool.
Where are we on?
20?
Yeah.
Each level now has multiple save.
I
don't know why I'm using up these bullets.
I'm an idiot.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, there is a key down there.
Come on.
There we go.
Give me, let me have the bullets, please.
Do you think it's safe?
Do you think it's...
Oh,
my God.
They're so obsessed with me.
Oh, no.
Their bodies disappeared.
I thought it was so cool.
There was, like, a whole thing of pinkies.
Wow, it's a lot of health.
It's pretty generous.
Nice.
Okay.
Uh.
Red key.
I'm hearing something.
But, like, not the ambiance.
I'm hearing.
I think I heard like a...
Which way do I go?
Uh...
Where am I?
Oh!
Okay, this was the secret room.
And then this goes...
This is where we just came from.
How do I leave?
Tommy Hort.
That was you, your tummy.
Oh.
Never mind, we don't need to leave.
We've got this.
That's the neat part.
You don't.
I'm figuring that out real fast.
Wow.
Hell is so great this time of year.
Oh my gosh.
Don't shoot me.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Just gonna...
Oh, dang.
I can't lift my tiny arms up high enough.
Oh my god!
Oh, I got three and one!
That's kind of cool.
It's kind of exciting.
Triple.
I don't think I've ever had a triple kill before.
Do you think Hell is more bearable than the current Earth
weather?
Summer just started.
Already 105.
Yeah, I got- wait.
Is it officially summer now?
Gosh, there's a lot of these.
A lot of like little...
Oh, there he is.
As of last Friday!
Wait, where does he go?
Oh, there's two of us.
Oh, no, no, I got stuck on the door.
Nice.
Not nice.
I mean, I still got stuck on the door, but...
Wow, happy summer!
I didn't realize that it happened already.
I feel really silly now.
I even have a...
I have a podcast based off of it being summer.
I don't even realize it was summer.
Silly mean.
I think Matara talked about it on her stream, so I'll
mention it too.
What the?
Oh my gosh.
You bastards.
Did you shoot each other?
I think they shot each other.
But basically, because our Japan trip kind of went haywire,
um we were trying to figure out when we can go go back and
um to to do the stuff that we wanted to do we basically
decided in august so wait what moved
something over there something over here
here Huh?
Am I missing it?
Uh, enjoy the weather.
Well, I mean, we would have gone in July, so it would have
been awful anyway.
Imagine being on summer.
LMAO, the Supo was sponsored by Southern Hemisphere Gang.
Yippee!
But yeah, it's just kind of what we gotta do.
Basically.
Maybe this is what opens up.
No, it's not.
Huh.
No, it's happening on my...
Yeah, it's happening on...
I have no idea.
Plasma gun!
Okay, we at least got that.
Oh.
Wait, this is where we came from.
Okay, never mind.
That's me.
When I think about going to Japan in summer.
Oh,
oh.
For some reason, I thought that this would, uh,
that that was going to be the thing that would open once I
pressed all the switches.
I'm so lost.
Yeah.
Cute.
This looks like it could open.
Where am I?
Do you plan on playing the custom Doom 2 level My House dot
Wad?
People have asked about it.
I...
Oh!
I am not going to say No.
Oh my gosh.
Because I don't really have a reason to say no.
I just don't have any plans to play it right now.
Like, to give a definitive like, oh yeah, I'm gonna play it
next week.
Kind of deal, you know.
Run.
Yeah.
Run from the lost souls.
Wee!
Just come up here, please.
my favorite enemy absolutely hmm how do we get to there
curious oh interesting hmm how do we get there to get the
sphere trying to save up to visit Japan where should I book
first my flight or a hotel I would say book your flight
first but also a lot of mean you could always book your
hotel first um but flights are gonna be the most expensive
thing so and they fluctuate so much hotel prices aren't
gonna fluctuate so much so it's kind of like you know if you
were to
if you were to get it and like um if you were to get your
hotel but the those specific dates are super duper expensive
it would really suck you know
no hotel prices no no no i meant the flight prices will
fluctuate not the hotel not the hotel the hotel prices are
pretty yeah now that now hoping that somebody makes a mint
mugshot mod for doom yeah but um how many of you get to that
door okay now we hit the thing oh we have the yellow key
that's right The yellow key was, uh...
Right.
Um, this is secret room.
This is room...
To...
Where you need...
The yellow key.
Right!
No.
Uh...
Hold on, we'll figure it out.
here see i knew it i told you guys what's this oh gosh
the exit the exit is this my doom or is this the exit the
exit your gameplay makes me want to play doom now i don't
know if that's a good way or a bad way Okay!
No sphere.
Too bad.
Only 31% of the items.
That's crazy.
Wait, we got more secrets than we got the items.
Time is it?
10.
Okay, I have an hour and a half.
Ooh, yikes.
Ouch!
Why do these guys never miss?
Red.
No.
I gotta pick up the pace.
Oh, save?
Yes, thank you.
We're at level 21!
Nice.
Oh, yellow key.
Oh, wow.
Good job.
I heard them.
I heard them to my left and to my right.
Oh my gosh.
Where are they?
They're like down... Oh, wait.
They're somewhere.
Oh, they're everywhere.
Oh my god, they're everywhere!
Don't fall.
Oh, that wasn't very nice of them.
Wipe his ass.
I'm... I'm trying!
I love sniping with the shotgun.
this area is really I don't like it because it's kind of
confusing me can I, like I can't tell can I drop down or
what and I hear more guys like over in here is this where
you're at?
oh my god you're a big guy in here and there's more over
there the ground is lava
how do I get in Hmm.
Guess someday.
Oh!
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm alive.
You know what?
Since we have this, though?
Go around.
Find everything.
There's another portal.
Oh, there's not much...
Never mind.
There's...
Wait.
Over here.
There's an arrow.
There's not much going on in here.
Woo!
Secret.
I can't hit them, I don't think.
Here?
Oh, they all lead to the same spot.
Green.
Mental vision.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, good thing I was far, far away from that wall.
There we go.
Got him, boys.
But how, I can't, okay, so running across that is kind of
useless.
Maybe something in here.
Who turned off the green?
Thank goodness they turned off the green.
My eyes.
This is what I'm doing.
what it's like living with ectoplasm.
Button.
I don't understand this level design at all.
I think.
I think I'm really confused.
Wait.
That's where we came from.
How are you enjoying the game so far?
It's so much fun!
And both Teleporters took me to the same place.
This one is
pretty complicated.
Is it this area?
Okay, this is probably a dumb idea.
Is it here?
Ah!
Wait, no, this is just a hole!
It is a place!
Just not the correct place!
Wait, up there even, oh no, it's just fire.
Just a hole.
Maybe I should run over...
Okay, I'm going to try.
Yeah!
Oh!
I did it.
Dang, I thought I could snipe that guy from...
Oh, come on.
Oh.
Yeah.
I just wanted to get rid of them in any way possible wait oh
my gosh yeah okay cool oh whoa wait okay uh double kill
double kill I'm the doom guy what's the point of Going up
here.
There's nothing here.
Right?
I'm not just blind.
Am I?
There's nothing here.
Um.
Uh.
Okay.
Keep looking.
Oh, I have to go the other way.
Lampy!
Thanks for another gift.
Thank you.
Okay.
Keep looking.
The music is making me feel clownish.
I'm looking to see if there's anything I can shoot.
I don't see anything though.
I don't see anything.
I think I've gone bonkers.
Oh!
I'll take that.
But nothing.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
free blueberry no strings attached let's go free blueberry
no strings attached
I think there's what uh 24 levels or something in this game
24 or 25 but I don't remember what you guys told me we're on
21 it could be that you know because these levels get way
more complicated I won't be able to finish today but I'm
gonna do my darndest he said nothing here and it echoed in
my mind as by a phantasmal russian i do it all the time
nothing here i'm maybe i just run wait no there's do i oh
there we go okay
this area is nice and all but there's nothing nothing Oh,
here we go.
Oh!
Wait, hold on a second.
Okay, never mind.
I figured it out.
All on my own.
Using my brain and my brain alone.
25 normal levels.
Oh, I thought it was 24.
Also, wait.
I need a red... I don't know, actually.
Oh my gosh.
This is the worst place to be stuck with you.
It's sooo narrow.
Sasago minto.
That looks like a door.
Oh, this looks like a door.
Actual jail!
Real jail!
Idiot.
Whoa!
Box of rockets.
Did it open up now?
Nope.
Horny jail!
Oh my god.
I sure hope not.
I don't want him thinking of me.
Wait.
So things are opening up and it's...
Oh gosh, this map, man.
This is where we just came from.
Yeah.
And then we went this way.
And we can go...
Oh wait.
This looks like an awfully...
bad idea.
I don't think I can go there.
What is that?
Oh, I got an area map!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
No, wait, I don't think I want that.
Uh-oh, wait a second.
I don't think I want an area map because I want to know
where I have not been before.
I don't know if I am a fan of that.
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh, stop roaring in my ear!
I don't like this RP anymore.
Stop roaring in my ear!
Nice.
Oh, it opened!
Here.
Okay.
Ew.
What?
What was that?
Did it open in here?
No, I think down here.
Oh my god.
Really bad.
Yikes!
Luckily, I thought...
Whoa!
That's quite the room for the blue key!
We're just gonna do that.
There we go.
I don't think there's anything.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't trust.
I have no trust.
I do not trust.
Ouchie.
I might just reset.
What am I?
I'm hard of seeing.
That's what I am.
How do I grab you?
Wait, I can't see anything!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna reload.
Sorry, guys.
Oh, that's the invincible!
I'm bulletproof!
Nothing to lose.
Fire away, fire away.
Ricochet, you take your aim.
Fire away.
you shoot me down but I won't fall I am titanium you shoot
me down but I won't fall I am titanium I said I was gonna do
many karaoke because I'm trying to like risk my voice.
Oh, I don't need those either.
Trying to risk my voice for like the concert and stuff.
But I just felt like doing it this week because I don't...
I'm not feeling so well.
And doing karaoke cheers me up even if it's just silly
music, silly songs.
Wait, there's a concert?
Yeah, I have a concert Anime Expo.
Virtual vacation!
It's not at Anime Expo but it's during the weekend.
Yes, resave.
Okay, cool.
Where was...
Oh
my god, that scared me.
Sinaf, thank you!
Oh my god.
I thought I heard, like, whispering.
It freaked me out.
It was my own voice.
Thank you so much.
I was like, Oh, here it is.
Another one?
You were so unoriginal.
I like the guy out the side of the door better.
Oh.
I don't know what else to expect.
Where do I go?
Wait, is this new?
Is this new?
Oh, this is where I came from, isn't it?
Save?
Yeah, you're right.
You're so right.
Okay.
Uh, it opened something somewhere.
Somewhere.
Maybe in here?
No, that has not opened yet.
Okay.
But we're keeping that in the back of our brains.
I think I'm going too far away.
Horny jail, unchanged.
Oh, this map.
Sounds like people...
Maybe this is a bit of an infamous map.
Due to how...
Uh...
Complicated?
It is!
In here.
No.
Quite changed.
I don't think any...
I don't see anything over there.
Wait, here?
No, I just made a circle.
What changed?
Oh my goodness.
I'm as zoomed out as I can be.
I hope there's nothing alive around here.
Maybe down here.
No.
Blue door?
That's where that's where we just came from though.
and we flip the switch that is now gone and something opened
up yeah we're still missing a red key unless we go back to
the main area but i don't know
oh that's a lamp maybe we go back to the main area
Oh.
Did this lift up?
No.
I am now... Oh, there's the red key over there.
You can see it.
I am now accepting hints.
You need to go back to the main area for the red key.
I am now accepting backseating advice.
Oh, wait.
Oh, maybe I lifted up this part.
Never mind.
Don't tell me anything.
I retract my statement.
Also, armor.
I did see it.
I did see the armor.
Okay.
Nia!
Nice!
Nice, nice.
I don't know.
I think I would get the armor.
I do need it, though, don't I?
I do need it.
No!
Wait, we can try again.
We can try again.
I think.
I do need it, though.
nice
lost a little bit of health but maybe it was worth it okay
now we go back oh to that one room oh my gosh I keep going
the wrong way we go back to the one door that had the yellow
and the red right I believe
speed ride It was right here.
What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
Maybe I shoot this.
Aha!
Ah!
You jerk.
Maybe this was nothing all along.
Can I?
Thank you.
Sorry, I swallowed my spit wrong.
Oh,
I picked up a clip.
Were there any other red areas?
Yeah, I already have a plastic.
my gun no worries besides there are there any other red
doors or
look at all these squirming squishy i'm not so sure guys i'm
not so sure where to go There's nothing in here.
Nothing here.
To hear about the redneck couple that found the blind
newborn deer.
Scientists came to see if it was a new species.
Said if they named it, they could keep it.
The wife said, that's a bad eye deer.
Eye deer.
Um.
I took so I took damage from that one I think I took that
Wait what's in there I think I took damage from that one I
love and hate it That's a bad idea I get it I get it I get
it I get it
yeah see there seems to be stuff inside
guys i'm not so sure i'm not so sure i know where to go what
to do we got the red key i know that there was uh i wonder
if the door actually hold on let's check the door because
there was a there was a door at the very very beginning
wasn't there i think Oh, but we've been locked out.
Oh, yes, it's open.
Here, here.
Wait, is this the exit?
The game is not so kind.
Well, maybe that opened it.
Maybe.
Okay.
I thought that was going to be the exit, which is why I
hadn't gone back to it.
But...
Aha!
Oh!
Of course you're here.
Of course you're here to ruin my day, to ruin my time, to
ruin my moment.
You're just here to be like, um, this is all about me.
It's not all about you, Mr. Baron.
It's not all about you.
Into the void!
Oh.
Minty sweat!
Welcome back.
Not that many secrets.
Burned off our heads.
Oh, the sky is literally just on fire now.
What?
Oh, that's really exciting.
I don't think
I'm hitting it.
Oh, yes I am.
Take that.
Spitter.
Oh, I thought that was a weapon.
Or a bad guy.
Okay.
Alright, run.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh, please, please!
I think I... Wait, hold on!
I accidentally hit caps lock!
Guys, I accidentally hit caps lock, which in turn...
Um...
Turned off my running for a brief moment.
Okay.
Save!
Oh gosh, I should have done that way beforehand, shouldn't
I?
Oopsie!
I should have done that before.
It's fine.
Maybe.
Okay, hold on.
Look at the sky.
Gosh!
Hell is...
Oh my god, so wonderful this time of year!
Oh,
I think I got these guys, or at least I got one of them
before, so I completely forgot about it.
Why are you leaping at me?
You freak?
Ah, could have been better, could have been worse.
Could have been better.
It could have been worse.
Oh.
Excuse you.
Trying to find all these things around here.
Oh my god, the chainsaw.
A berserk.
Come here, little pickle.
Pinky pickle.
A chainsaw, what?
A mother trucking chainsaw, what?
Well, so come and get it.
What does the orb do?
What does the pearl do?
Mega health and armor.
Oh, boy.
200, 200?
Wait, I thought it was...
What's in here?
Okay, hold on.
Get ready.
Oh.
I can't read it.
I was like, okay, here I go!
I like bread and butter pickles.
Like...
What does that entail?
A bread and butter pickle?
butter pickle.
Like, I've heard of butter pickles before.
Give me a key or something!
I don't want your ugly ass!
Oh, there's a key up there.
What the?
You thought you were sneaky, huh?
Is that a... a... yes.
A meatball!
It's a meatball!
You know you've played...
You know you've played too much when you actually can start
recognizing like the different...
The different noises.
You're like, that's the sound of a...
Of a meatball!
Oh.
call that fire look at it
ah yes oh my gosh what a lovely view from the balcony ah oh
my nose is soft don't listen to that actually
there we go taking in all that smoke carbon dioxide very guy
fears True, true, true, true.
He would love this place.
Do you think he's the devil?
Wait, how do I get the blue key?
It's up there.
From that window, maybe?
The condiments are...
Oh, wait.
Ah.
No!
Wait, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Wow!
I got it.
I hope there wasn't anything else up there, actually.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Let's do it one more time.
One more time.
Six minutes before 1130?
No, no.
I have one more hour.
One more hour.
But thank you for Thank you for being for for checking.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, nice.
Well, any more?
Anyone else want to test me?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
Where's my free blueberry after that?
What?
I deserve a blueberry after that.
After that.
I almost died.
You failed the test.
But how else was it supposed to have me to do?
I'm open.
How else was the door supposed to open?
The pearl is nearby, but I can't...
My legs are too short.
I'm too...
There was a secret room.
There was!
Hmm.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'll be back for you.
Wow, I saw it, seven.
Thank you for the birthday.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You've been a huge inspiration to be working extra hard and
getting waxed and honey this year in hopes of eventually
having something to show off to my Oshi.
What are you talking about?
I already think it's so cool that you do the whole B thing
in general.
That guy.
Wait a second.
I was going to say, this guy looks a little different.
He looks...
Wait.
This guy looks really funky.
What are you hiding here?
What are you hiding?
I think I have to go.
up to the other.
I have to go back up there.
Hold on.
Oh, there is health here.
Thank goodness.
Okay.
You!
Oh!
Blueberry!
Yay!
What?
Wow!
That guy was, I was gonna say he looks, oh, can I come up?
He looked a little different.
Now I'm getting greedy.
Everybody must have a blueberry body.
There's also this over here.
This is all water, so I'm assuming if we fall, it'll be
okay.
We have a blue key.
Where was the blue door?
Over... yon.
When did this open?
Is that a spider over there?
Just gonna...
That was close.
That was a close one.
Anyone else in here?
I'm not gonna ask anybody if they want to test me ever again
because I learned my lesson.
Coco daemon
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Minto ball No We're ball Oh my gosh, I saw, did you guys,
okay, do you guys fall like, um I, you guys like, do you
guys know the Yeti?
They, um, they, uh, Make like t-shirts and stuff like that
and I saw that they put one went out today that was a it was
just Garfield and it says sometimes I'm balling and it shows
Garfield playing b-ball and then it says some or some or
sometimes I'm balling and it just shows him crying I was
like Garfield no Garf Garf okay yellow key means uh yellow
door was uh Uh, oh, over there, over there.
Like, going to get the Miku Garfield figure.
Isn't there a U-Tus, though?
I'm not...
I'm not really a fan.
I mean, the...
The U-Tuser.
Oh, my God.
Wait, no, don't kill me.
I don't want to die.
There was a blueberry right there!
Every time.
Not every time.
Don't be dramatic.
What?
Someone's snoring up a storm in there.
Oh, I think it was him.
Oh, just kidding.
There's more sleepy, lazy guys.
See?
Blueberry, all good.
Mint Slayer, Hater of Wisps, Protector of Oshis, Slate the
Demons.
I'm not a Hater of Wisps.
No.
Look at these losers in jail.
What is this?
What's gonna happen in here?
It's a tarp!
Oh.
Is every single one gonna open up or...
That's a lot of rockets!
Whoa!
Whoa, this is actually kind of cool.
Oh, I need to...
Okay, fine, I'll open the door!
They were like, why are you standing inside there, little
baby?
What are you standing inside there for, little baby?
Little baby.
Little baby, a little baby.
What did that do?
Oops, wrong one.
Oh, I gotta open the door.
Little baby, a little baby.
Don't just stand inside here.
Nice.
Okay, Red Kia Kui.
Yard.
You again.
I'm afraid of blowing up on myself.
There we go.
Okay.
Anyone else?
gonna come out wait what is this over here then i don't
think we're done you guys i don't think we're quite so done
oh wait what the exit oh my god ouch ouch ouch huh but the
exit wow this room's really pretty can you climb the little
ledge around the water Oh yeah, I see it.
It would be you.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
What just opened?
Come on, come on, Doomguy.
This is why you have tiny legs.
Be careful, Minto.
Do you think...
Do you think it was the orb?
No.
How do I get you?
Unless it's a timed thing.
What do you guys think?
Do you think it's timed?
Okay, let's try it again.
Hidden door by the blue door.
Oh wait, this also went up!
Give me a...
It's just a gun that I don't need.
Hidden door by the blue door.
Blue door.
Blue door?
Here.
Oh!
Secret!
I'm sorry.
Hey!
Burnt offerings.
Secrets?
Unholy temple!
Okay, hold on.
Let me save the game before we do anything else.
Yes.
It's okay.
Goodbye secret level.
23!
We have three more levels, I think, right?
She listens to our backseating.
Yeah, because I trust you, God!
Thank you for the help.
Thank you.
Yeah, the fire is green now.
You're right.
Um.
No, yeah.
You're not gonna come down here, you little baby.
I like the snarl that, uh...
That Pinky's make.
Do you think I can hit him?
Wha!
Nope.
I hear another one.
I know probably.
It might be overkill, but...
I just feel safer.
Oh, oh shoot!
I didn't think it would reach me because most of them hit
the walls.
Ripperoni, we just got the orb.
I'm sniping with my shotgun!
Sometimes I can hit me and sometimes I can't!
Idiot!
Get shotgun sniped!
Oh, we need all three for this door.
How do I get up there anyway?
I hear a spider in there.
Uh, not here.
I'd like to take them out if I could, because I'd like to
not go up there and have to deal with them.
Ah!
Sniping with shotguns.
Yeah, you know.
All the best gamers do it.
It's like totally in normal, natural.
Meta, everybody.
And you know meta.
There we go.
Meta is everything, right?
Meta over.
Wifu.
Holy...
Wait, what?
What just happened?
Wait, what just actually...
Wait, huh?
These things up there, maybe?
Oh my god.
Oh.
They're like homing!
Can you take the armor, please?
Listen, they were like homing missiles, though.
How do I get up?
Does this...
Open up, please!
Wall missiles.
Oh, oh my gosh.
That's where they are.
At least I got one.
There we go, two!
What just opened up?
I heard a sound.
No, those aren't cyber demons.
They were just the...
The barons, right?
Oh my god.
Ah!
Stop!
Don't do this to me!
Please!
Oh never mind not like this oh so rude oh here we go
something opened up I'm going around I'm checking everything
checking what's going on I can't oh wait how do I get out of
here it's not timed I Wait, here we go.
Okay.
Holy.
Is Mint winning?
I think so.
I don't know.
Probably.
I think so.
See, it doesn't happen every time.
Yeah!
Face in my fury!
Why are you falling?
Why are their pinkies falling from the sky?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
This is getting ridiculous.
I took less damage than I expected to.
Am I gaming?
Okay, nice.
Minto gaming open up please I did your stupid task give me
the key I did your task please please give me the key I did
what you asked of me
Open up, please!
Oh, here it is.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
I'll be back for you.
I guess.
What?
I can't shoot him, but this guy can shoot me.
Wait.
No, no, no, I don't... I don't trust it.
I don't trust it.
Where was he?
Anyway, okay, so we got the blue key, which was very much of
a place that I remember.
Actually, it doesn't even show on the map.
It doesn't show on...
I don't remember seeing a blue door.
Oh, okay, good.
Me neither.
Stop shooting at me.
I can't get through.
I don't have a yellow or a red.
I think the game put us in the wrong order.
Oh!
Let me...
Oh,
come on.
This is so cheap.
okay red i was gonna say have they had enough time to
replenish the the bombs but clearly they have i'm gonna save
again sorry guys i'm gonna save again okay okay
oh there's a lot of guys in here
i think i'm glad i'm saved i i think i'm glad i saved I
think I'm glad I saved.
I think I'm glad I saved.
Where was the other guy?
There was just another random dude in here!
Where'd he go?
I hope I killed him.
Oh my god.
These guys!
Oh my god, please.
I will actually die.
Ah!
There's another one gonna pop up!
There's another one gonna pop up, please say no.
I was prepared this time.
Oh, come on.
Wait, exit.
Oh, I have a hundred, my bad.
Rude game, rude game, rude, rude.
Okay, we're safe right now.
Rude, rude, rude, rude, rude.
I love that the PNGs in this game all turn towards you.
Because I know it's probably like, you know, it's so that
they never appear flat but it also just makes it so much
spookier super rude so so rude good thing i saved beforehand
i suppose okay um what is what is this okay let's go grab
this and uh cool so now we have all wait we have all three i
just realized
That's filled with excitement as they react to a player
named Minto Gaming.
They use phrases like, Yes, you are Minto and True Gamer if
I ever saw one.
Yippee!
Okay.
Let's keep going then.
Yes!
You are Minto.
Wait, why is this closed back up?
This is so rude.
There's still health in here.
Okay.
I'm just gonna blast him.
Oh, I don't think that actually worked.
I don't think that actually...
I don't think I actually aimed for him at all.
There we go.
Took care of his meaty ass.
I'm gonna go get also...
This.
Ah!
This game is so rude.
This game is so unbearably rude.
Come on, I have all three.
What am I hearing?
I don't actually remember how I got up here, to be honest.
I don't quite remember.
Oh.
Take this.
Oh, the portal!
Yes, thank you.
Thank you.
It was all the way on the other side.
Wait, no.
On this side.
Yes, there was a teleporter.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for the reminder.
Thank you, thank you.
This one.
Okay.
Run, run!
Please God, no!
Oh no, why did I come in?
Why did I come back in here?
I'm such an idiot.
Of all places I could have picked for protection.
What's wrong with me?
Go, go, go, go.
Oh, it's open again.
Oh,
I didn't realize this was a...
no.
We're okay.
I'll come back for you, my precious.
Um...
I came back for you!
What?
Oh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, we're good.
I'm coming back for you.
No.
I did it.
Wait, how do I open these now?
They said don't leave me, darling.
I know, I really did.
Carly Ray Minto.
I'm coming back for you.
I don't know.
Okay, so we have all the keys, but all the doors that
require the three keys are not opening.
Is that at 11 or 11.30?
11.30.
Guys, I don't think we're finishing.
I'm so sad.
No, I wanted to finish!
Maybe if my meeting isn't so long, I can continue
afterwards, after it's done.
Even though it'll be quite late.
Oh, save.
Thank you.
Thank you for the reminder.
Um, I don't...
Wait, okay.
Late night mint.
Late night minto.
Oh, that's that in there.
Um...
So we pushed those three.
So what else?
Maybe the one inside here.
No.
There was another one.
Oh my god, I completely forgot!
And this one's probably also gonna go off too!
Ah!
The key buttons are in a sequence.
Oh!
Wait.
Go back to the room where you fought all the pinkies.
But I- I know I went back in there though.
And it wasn't open.
In here.
This one.
Have you tried knocking politely?
Pink, pink, pink.
Open up, please.
Oh, wait a second.
Wait a second.
Red, blue, yellow.
Hold on, I'm cooking.
What was the other one?
The one in here.
Red, blue, yellow.
Are they timed?
I should open.
Oh!
Ah!
Blue, yellow, red.
Blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow, red.
Red, blue, yellow.
Ah-ha!
Ah-ha-ha!
Oh!
Blue, yellow, red.
Oh, shoot.
Guys, which one was that?
that?
Uh,
not red?
Shoot.
No, yeah.
Oh, this way.
Oof, oof, oof, oof, oof.
This one.
The one over there.
Yes.
Ta-da!
Okay.
Then red, blue, yellow is the next one.
And then there was the one all the way downstairs.
I do remember the one in the water.
Oh.
Red, blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow.
Red.
Blue, yellow.
Nice.
Okay.
Thank you.
Someone gave me a hint.
They were like, there's a sequence.
So it wasn't my big brain all by myself.
So thank you for the hint.
And then we gotta go see what the last one is.
It's somewhere...
It's over here, I believe.
Just kidding.
It's here.
Oh, I already unlocked it because I'm stupid!
Yippee!
What's he doing up there?
I'm a secret genius!
I'm
a secret genius!
I'm a secret genius!
Yeah!
what else is coming down what's coming down oh this beep
beep beep oh did the floor turn the lava uh oh
my phone is going off it's like your meeting is in 30
minutes i know no Oh gosh, okay.
Oh, come on.
Maybe it
wasn't the best idea of staying up there.
Maybe it wasn't the best idea.
That should be the third one.
And then...
Something amazing will happen.
Something...
Really cool!
Wait, where am I?
Oh, okay.
Thanks, I guess, for that.
Wow!
Something.
Meow!
Oh, the exit!
The exit, the exit, the exit, the exit, the exit.
The exit, the room that said exit!
This way!
No surprises!
No escape!
Save game.
Gosh, we're so close, you guys.
Oh, we're so close!
I wish I could postpone my meeting for real.
I wish I could be like, um, can you give me like...
A little extra time to beat the game?
Could you just...
How much for a checky with the cute maid?
Stop it.
Could you just give me a little extra time to beat the game?
Whoa, wee.
There's a lot going on here.
You're shooting each other.
You're shooting your friend.
I thought I could climb on top of that.
What's going on here?
Is that a cyber demon?
What does that sound?
Oh, oh my goodness.
Oh.
Sounds...
Can't even tell if I'm getting him or not.
Oh my god, these are so fu- Toho!
Toho project!
No, hey, people said there were only 25 levels.
Which is it?
I'm so confused.
Ah!
If you're counting secret levels, then...
Oh my gosh.
If you're counting secret levels, I'm not gonna do secret
levels, so...
It's okay.
They added more levels with the re-release?
Oh my god.
Okay, then maybe it will be another day.
Come on!
Where are you?
Oh, I see him.
Cyber demon.
Let's see.
There's a lot going on here.
Oh.
Just kidding.
Wait, this is where I came from.
Okay.
Well, if we ever need health, we know where to get some.
Chad's a bit lost in the...
I'm lost in the sauce.
I don't know what's going on at all.
Wait, a box of what?
Oh no!
Wait.
It's just like that, that one puzzle where you get the
special thing.
Okay, I'm not going to press anymore.
Spank!
Thanks for the tang gifted.
Thank you.
Can I go any?
I don't think I can.
It's just, it's really sad.
Watching his corpse rise and fall.
Okay, let's see.
Cyber daemon?
I think I gotta go down here.
Whoa!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, nice.
Womp, womp.
Okay.
Uh.
Oh my god.
Lost levels are unlocked after beating the original
campaign.
They came with a 2020 release.
I see, I see.
There's 25 story levels.
A little 25, 26, and 27 are fun levels that can be accessed
with passwords.
Oh, we don't need that.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and go from here, maybe?
Oh wait!
Oh!
How did I get... Why is the sky black back to...
Back to... um, red?
I really enjoyed our green flame scenery before.
Yeah, I'm just confused.
I think, yeah, I'll just keep playing until the game is
over, I guess.
Rip and tear until it is done, you know?
That's what...
Isn't that what are they all the greatest?
Um, all the greatest, uh, uh, Doomguy's say and everything,
you know?
Rip and tear part of your schedule.
I'm really kind of not sure when I'll be able to play it,
though.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Wait a second.
Are there any other things that look like...
Oh yeah, there are.
Let's see what else we can open.
Well, I'll take all the rockets.
That's what I will do.
All the greatest doomers are saying that nowadays.
Exactly!
Oh.
I just got this armor!
Don't break it.
Okay.
Where even is that?
I have no idea.
How many rockets did I waste?
Uh, did I go in this one?
They're always saying it.
If I decide to do one.
Yeah, if I decide, uh, I might, you know, I might just be
too tired.
Because I'll be...
Oh wait, this is the one I went into before.
I might just be too tired.
Because...
I'll be enduranceing tomorrow as well.
Okay, this is the way we need to go.
This is the way that just opened up.
Gosh, I'm so sorry.
I hate them so much.
I don't really want to be screaming at like 2 in the
morning, but you know.
You know how it is.
Oh!
lie.
Don't be a don't be a trap.
There we go.
It's not always a trap.
There's been one time it wasn't a trap.
And I'm going to hold on to that one chance.
Okay, there's definitely something I need to do in here.
I just... I'm worried that it's gonna be like that...
thing where I missed out on the cool weapon.
Oh!
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
You can go up, you can go up, you can go up.
Oh, sorry.
You can go up, you can go up.
Oh.
Save?
Yeah, that's a good idea.
That's a good idea.
Okay.
Please.
I'm...
I would like for you to go up.
Oh.
Oh, God!
I thought I was...
I thought I was trapped in it.
Wait, the same one keeps dropping down.
and like, an order to it?
Oh, secret ending.
You're just trapped.
I'm so glad that they thought that people might do that and
decided that if you interact with it, you can get away from
it.
Yeah, all the switches do the same thing.
What else is there?
I can't get up here, so...
Oh, wait.
Maybe I can shoot it.
Try the elevator nearby.
Yep, that's exactly whatever he's about to do.
Oh.
I wonder if I can get him a little bit.
I don't think so.
Well, that didn't do much.
Yeah, I want to get the cyber demon.
But he's like way in there.
Sniping with the Unmaker?
That's such a good idea.
It's so thin, right?
Come here.
Oh, I keep missing my chance.
How big is this hitbox?
I don't think it's working.
Maybe I get closer.
Oh, there we go.
I think.
I'm not seeing any blood.
That might just be wasting ammo.
I don't think it's working, you guys.
I don't think it's working.
It doesn't show damage.
Just keep shooting.
Oh, that one definitely hit.
That one definitely hit yeah oh oh
my god i did the real hacks i feel like a speed run i mean i
didn't speed run it at all but oh whoa what is that wait
this is the same thing that i'm holding oh my goodness um
They're like, hey, are you ready for this?
I don't think you are.
Wait, I'm at level 28!
Huh?
I'm at level 28.
Um.
Just grab everything.
BFG!
I'm scared.
I'm a bit frightened.
It's quiet.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Is these damn fossils?
I swear.
I think I can just rock it from here.
Oh, shoot.
Oh,
project.
Where did that guy come from?
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
It's like a floating fetus.
What is this thing?
BFG, the crowd?
Oh, okay.
But it's so slow.
The BFG is so slow.
Please use the BFG.
Okay, okay, okay, I'll use the BFG.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll use the B- Oh, wait, let me just load the game.
What am I doing?
Okay, okay, okay I'll use the BFG.
I use the BFG.
Okay, okay, okay.
Which one number is that?
Is this the BFG?
Yeah.
But it's so slow, I'm nervous.
I'm nervous, I'm nervous.
Well, I guess I'm going to resave.
But once we get out everything, there's no coming back.
So...
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, back, back.
Sorry.
Hold on.
And then...
Wait.
Save?
Yes.
Yeah, grab the invincibility.
Here we go!
Come on!
Hurry up, you guys!
I
don't think the BFG was really it you guys Oh shoot I'm just
Oh shoot Oh shoot Oh shoot I don't think it was it I don't
think that was I don't think that was I don't think that was
I don't think that was it I don't think that was it I don't
think I don't think BFG is close range Okay Okay Okay
understandable.
I don't use it very often, so...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
I'm so doomed, I think.
I think I'm so doomed.
Oh, there's a backside to this.
Hold on.
Are you guys sure the PFT?
It uses way too much power for it to be like...
I don't know.
Okay, hold on.
Let me get my...
This guy.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Please!
Oh my gosh, please!
I just run in circles.
Run in circles.
Run in circles, man.
The Doom... Doom guys, run in circles man, run in circles
man, run in circles man.
Oh my
god.
You bitch.
They're so annoying!
They're the worst enemy in the world!
They're the most obnoxious thing I've ever had to encounter
in my life!
And afterlife!
And everything!
And my whole existence!
Okay.
All right.
Ah!
I think these guys are going to make me become the Joker for
real.
Please, please!
No, I pressed 4!
I think I accidentally pressed 5 instead of...
Oh my god.
There's still another one!
And I have no more ammo for this guy.
Um.
Eep!
What the hell?
Oh, how did I take damage?
Was it me?
Splash damage?
Ouch.
Oh my god, I'm flying.
What the heck?
BFG now I had no ammo!
What are you talking about?
Ammo!
I had no more BFG ammo.
I used it all.
Okay, hold on.
I think I was an idiot.
BFG is for when they are all spawned in in a big crowd.
You need to let them come into the area first.
Maybe chain gun.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, my W key wasn't working for a second.
Come on!
We're
so close!
Oh,
we're gonna die.
Why is the BFG so bad?
everyone's giving different answers so it's just so
confusing but i i did the best when i did my own way so but
also i gotta go to a meeting you guys oh oh my gosh my
discord just was totally off oh
okay man on the very last thing i'm gonna look up some
guides on how to what to do
I'll see if after my meeting if I can continue the boss is
BS but I know you can beat it good luck at the meeting thank
you what this is such BS what is this oh my gosh it's just a
it's just a pew pew everything give them out but they need
to give you more ammo after you defeat all of them I think
the boss itself is kind of cheap yeah and he's got the
homing you first have to deal with so much and then he's got
he shoots you into the air and you got the homing
everything's and this and that
whatever the meeting is about hope it goes well thank you
for the stream thank you thank you sorry that i've been
having so much stuff that interferes with stream um but uh
yeah like i said wait i'm just gonna you know i am gonna
save this one as well oh wait oh i almost saved over the
last thing yes um just in case i think they give you
everything that you need at the beginning of this but um you
know oh i will see you guys maybe later i don't like i said
i don't know how long this is gonna be if it's like a half
hour to 45 minutes then i'll probably stream afterwards but
if it's a little bit longer um and this is the last level
please right it is the last level right and drago's thanks
for the 10 gifted because if it's not the last level i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna stream it is okay mint phantom okay
because i really want to beat it today um dang i was so
close i was so close to i was like man i think i'll be able
to beat it today I was so close I'm relieved Do you have a
copy of Ace Combat 2?
I believe so, yes But thank you
Okay, Otamito Otamito Go to your meeting Thank you I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go party And then I'm gonna go to my meeting
And then I'll see you guys Maybe later Otamito Bye bye bye
bye bye Bye bye
I'm so frustrated though I was like I can't do this What the
heck I'm so What the heck It's okay though It's okay I'll
get through the meeting And then I'll do my best to finish
it Like I said I'm going to look up a guide I'm going to go
I'm going to go to the bathroom And I'm going to look up
Like so and so Feeding the final boss
Surely a cruel game.
I know.
Do it normally.
Okay, I'm just going to knock you out.
I'll just keep streaming, but I'll turn off my mic and turn
off all the sound, and you guys can just watch me.
I want to beat Area 27.
No, 28.
28.
Okay.
Otomito.
Bye-bye.